vous êtes arrivé vos oeillères ce que
vous sentez une quelconque inquiétude de
la part des voyageurs face à la couvrir
parce que ça s'est bien passé ça s'est
extrêmement bien passée de l'arrivée à
l'aéroport de montréal trudeau à
l'arrivée ici par dumas les consignes
sont aussi bien respecté ici au québec
les gens sont très relax il ya peu de
québécois par contre ça commence à
arriver mais un peu moins de québécois
que usuellement quelles sont les mesures
en place qu'après nous un peu celles qui
sont en place du côté de la floride le
port du masque est obligatoire pour
résumer en fait c'est exactement un
copier coller du québec par contre ici
les restaurants sont ouverts
donc on a accès à l'eau au restaurant il
ya le 6 à 10 pieds qui respecte et on
est allé mots choisis et a soif six à
dix pieds les gens font extrêmement
attention par du fichier de la vision et
les nuits du mas pour chacun les gens
sont très près son traître historiens
avec lui est ce que les américains les
respecte ces mesures sanitaires
honnêtement oui j'avais un peu
l'impression avant d'arriver que j'aurai
des gens qui seraient plus délinquants
entre guillemets mais non je vois je
vous confirme se verra que les gens font
attention autant que chez nous monsieur
dans le dans le comté où est ce que je
suis mais on s'entend assez beau solo il
ya pas de ces pas sans risques le risque
zéro n'existe pas il ya c'est un état
qui est particulièrement touchée on
approche les 1000 cas depuis le début de
la pandémie chaque jour là on est à plus
de 8000 cas on approche la barre des dix
mille nouveaux cas quotidiens comme ça a
été le cas il ya quelques mois
qu'est-ce qu'il faut avoir en main avant
de partir une bonne assurance j'imagine
tout à fait d'accord avec vous la
question numéro un il faut se poser
snowboard personne qui voyage chez quel
type d'assurance que nous avons en notre
possession pour partie parce que c'est
vraiment ce qui est vraiment le plus
important il faut faire attention aux
surmonter c'est là je pense que là la
partie se joue chez les assurances et le
montant assurables à destination avant
de parler de ce montant il faut
s'assurer qu'on est couvert en code de
de contamination la coved 19 ça c'est
pas toutes les assurances qui inclut
sont maintenant c'est de plus en plus je
c'est un cheminement plusieurs embarque
il considère le risque profite comme
étant un risque connu
mais c'est vraiment le montant sur abl
que je veux que les gens portent la
passion à 200 mille dollars 200 milles
de lens pas suffisant sincèrement non à
200 milles je pense qu'on vous a même
passé du vôtre
et encore il faut voir exactement s'il
faut aller beaucoup plus que ça faut
viser le lin 2 3 4 5 millions ce
possible il ya quand même un défi
partout sur la planète des ressources
supérieures il ya énormément de cas il
n'y a pas nécessairement de la place
d'un des hôpitaux pour tous les malades
si on tombe malade comme canadiens ont
fleuri même si on a une assurance est ce
que on a la garantie qu'on va avoir des
soins nécessaires moi je me suis posé la
question et j'ai fait quelques
vérifications des hôpitaux ne sont pas
tous complets j'ai pas j'ai pas
l'inquiétude est soigné je n'ai pas
l'impression qu'on aurait refusé dans
n'importe quel hôpital et on vous le
souhaite pas tomber malade mais si ça
arrive
vous êtes assurés est ce que votre
assureur
va tenter de vous ramener ici au pays le
plus rapidement possible qu'est ce qui
est prévu dans des cas comme ça prenons
la suivante je ferai en améliorant la
séance croix bleue c'est avec la can
avec laquelle je voyage ait eu aussi des
assurances via des cartes de crédit
l'assurance croix bleue eux nous
couvrent ici jusqu'à un montant de 5
millions donc je suis pas jusqu'à 100
millions et advenant leur corps que
c'est une longue hospitalisation et tous
y aura rapatriement ici tous à leurs
preuves
ça fait partie des frais de subsistance
et d'encadrement depuis et l'assurance
médicale ici et quand vous étiez
rapatriement ce sera organisé par votre
assureur par le gouvernement non content
de voir maman c'est vraiment par la
chercher à l'assureur de prendre en
charge bon et au retour on va espérer le
cas votre tour vous allez être
parfaitement santé mais là vous allez
devoir vous isolez c'est ça ouais ouais
c'est planifié j'ai 14 ans je reviens ce
samedi prochain je suis quand même et je
vais faire mon 14e à la maison à mon
retour
les années comme un bon citoyen je vais
respecter les consignes gouvernementales
ce qu en terminant les québécois les
cowboys qui se déplace vers la floride
sont essentiellement des gens qui quoi
ont déjà des propriétés sur place la
très grande majorité actuellement oui
généralement on eu beaucoup de étant
gens voyagent de conseillers en voyages
on avait beaucoup de croisiéristes des
croisières sont presque tous arrêtés on
dirait 98%
donc on n'a pas cette manne touristique
le sait beaucoup de locaux des gens qui
ont des propriétés lit ou qui viennent
ici pour du long séjour loin des maisons
doit des condos c'est vraiment du lot
saison et vous êtes confiant qu'il va
avoir d'autres nombreux qui vont suivre
c'est des premiers avec se sont rendus
ben moi je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de
méthodes maintenant les gens mettent
leurs photos sur des camions qui
traversent la frontière où il y en a qui
traverse à plattsburgh sens bien ici
mais y'en a beaucoup de fonds le
transport du véhicule du québec jusqu'à
ici ça arrive les par avion on peut
passer par l'avion ait aucun problème
et selon moi oui aucun cas la neige
tombera joreige écouter votre bloc météo
juste avant moi je pense que les gens
vont avoir un intérieur de plus en plus
arrêter nous il fait un degré c'est à
montréal aujourd'hui aller
27 degrés merci beaucoup pour cette
entrevue monsieur boissinot excellente
journée